many times in chemistry we'll see
different molecules that have the same
constituent atoms for example these two
molecules here they both have four
carbons 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 so if I were to
write their chemical formula BC for and
then they both have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 hydrogen's so both
of them both of them have the chemical
formula c4h10 c4h10 but they're still
fundamentally different molecules and
you can see that because they have
different bonding for example over here
we have a carbon that is bonded to three
other carbons in a hydrogen over here I
can't find any carbon that's bonded to
three other carbons I can find ones that
are bonded to two other carbons but not
one that's bonded to three other carbons
so how we've put the atoms together is
actually different they're bonded to
different things and so when we have
this situation where you have the same
constituent atoms where you have the
same chemical formula but you're still
dealing with different different
molecules because of either what their
how their how their bonds are made or
how their what their shape is we call
those isomers so an isomer isomer you
have the same chemical formula same
chemical formula formula but you could
have different bonding but different
different bonding bonding or shape
bonding shape or orientation or
orientation so over here you have just
different bonding and this type of
isomer is called a structural isomer so
these characters are structural isomers
same constituent atoms but different
bonding structural isomers so that's
structural isomers right right over
there now when you look at this pair
this pair you see why those will look
like structural isomers ality they have
the same constituents both of these for
example have four carbons four carbons
and they
both have one two three four five six
one two three four five six seven eight
and they both have eight hydrogen's so
we could both these are both c4h8 h8 it
looks like they're bonded similarly for
example I mean the left-hand side here
these look identical and on the
right-hand side you have a carbon bonded
to another carbon then it's bonded to
three hydrogen's carbon bonded to
another carbon that's bonded to three
hydrogen's carbon bonded to hydrogen
carbon bonded bonded to a hydrogen so it
looks like the struck the bonding that
everything is bonded to the same things
but you might notice a difference over
here on the right-hand side this ch3 is
on the bottom right
while over here it's on the it's on the
top right and you might say okay well we
know what's the big deal there these you
know all these molecules are all moving
around maybe they're rotating with
respect to each other and these things
could this thing could have rotated down
to become what we have up here if this
was a single bond a single bond would
allow for that type of rotation it would
allow for these things to rotate around
each other for the thing the molecule to
rotate around that bond but a double
bond does not allow that rotation so
this fixes these two things this fixes
these two things in place and because of
that these are actually two different
molecules over here on the top you have
the ch3 groups they're both they're both
on there both I guess you could say
facing down or they're both on the same
side of the double bond while over here
they are on different sides they are on
different sides of the double bond and
so this type of isomerism
where you have the same constituent and
you even have the same bonding this is
called stereoisomerism so we're here
we're carrying much more about how
things sit in three dimensions not we
don't just care about what's bonded to
water the constituents and actually this
one is we'll see this is also
stereoisomer because this carbon is
bonded to the same things in either case
so these are both these are both
situations these are both stereo isomers
stereo stereo isomers and this
particular variation
stereoisomer it's called a sis trans
isomer sis is when you have the two
groups on the same side sis and trans is
when you have the two groups on the
opposite sides of the double bonds sis
trans isomers sis trans isomers isomers
and these are often called geometric
isomers geometric geometric isomers so
that's a subset so when I'm talking
about sis trans or geometric I'm talking
about these two characters over here
they are a subset of stereo isomers now
what's going on over here have no double
bond I'm not talking about sis and trans
the carbon as I just said is bonded to
fluorine chlorine bromine and hydrogen
fluorine bromine chlorine and hydrogen
how are these two things different and
the way that they're different is if you
were to actually try to superimpose them
on each other you will see that it is
impossible they are mirror images of
each other and because there's four
different constituents here you can
actually not you cannot superimpose this
molecule onto this molecule over here
and actually because of that they
actually have different chemical
properties and so this over here these
these two characters which is a subset
of stereo isomers stereo isomers are
concerned with how things are are
positioned in three dimensions not just
their how their bonding is different but
this subset where you have these mirror
images that cannot be superimposed we
call these enantiomers so these two
characters these are enantiomers
enantiomers and an and show comes from
Greek the Greek word or the Greek root
opposite so these are opposites of each
other and they cannot be superimposed
they're mirror they're mirror images so
all of these are different variations of
isomers and once again you might say
okay these are clearly two different
molecules I have different bonding but
even sis trans isomers will have
different molecular will have different
chemical properties these two in
particular they aren't that different
but they do have different chemical
properties but sometimes they're so
different that one might be able to
exist in a biological system while the
other is not one might be okay for your
health and the other might not be okay
for your health same thing for
enantiomers one might be biologically
active in
certain way and the other one might not
be biology biologically active in that
same way